uh before that though i want to talk
about the related situation in ukraine
concerns about how to get the grain out
of ukraine whether there can be a
corridor uh in the black sea where
there's going to be safe passage for the
grain to get out of ukraine if that
doesn't happen there is significant
concerns
about people in africa and also asia who
may well starve let's speak to general
richard barrens former commander of
joint forces command hello to you thank
you so much for taking the time to join
us this morning how big a worry is it
about this grain corridor whether or not
it happens
it's it's a major worry it's one of the
most
damaging effects of this war is that the
grain that ukraine normally supplies to
africa asia and elsewhere is not getting
out by sea and there's so much of it
that if you try to move it by by rail it
takes two years to get one year's crop
out so in order to contain the effects
of this war one way or another that
grain has to get out
more than 100 days since this war first
began how much longer can it last
well there's no there's no script and
there's no rule that says a war like
this with a front line that's a thousand
miles long is is going to quit but it's
going to be quick it may have pauses and
we may see in the donetsk in a couple of
weeks if the russians feel that they've
got as far as they want to go or simply
run out of steam that there is a pause
but that does not mean that the fight is
over and we should expect this war to
continue well into next year even if it
comes and goes a bit
okay russian defense minister um saying
that russia has now liberated 97
of the luhansk region um
first of all do you think that can be
true and secondly if that is the case
does that then lend itself to the
argument that you just put forward which
means that there could be a pause so i
think we're at a we're at a very telling
point now uh russia occupies about 20 of
ukraine and 97
of luhanskan and close on at least 85 of
the donbass region
as a whole and the absolute key question
is
when russia feels that it has gone as
far in the donbass as it as it needs to
go and it is fighting this brutal
grinding battle expending vast amounts
of ammunition and councils to get there
has it run out of steam or does it
simply decide to pause before coming
back elsewhere this year and we won't
know the answer to that for some time on
balance it looks like in the donbass
they're running out of steam
why is the russian invasion having such
an impact on global resources
well i think we looking at the combined
effects of the isolation of of russia
and the sanctions regime that's applied
to russian energy and then the effects
on
global food markets particularly grain
as a result of the blockade on ukraine
and indeed the difficulty in getting
grain out of out of russia and we need
to recognize that in a world of
globalized supply chains any any big war
between big countries is going to ripple
across the world in this sort of way
and and the fact is we're going to have
to manage the consequences of this if
we're going to do the right thing by
ukraine
um okay
we've been hearing from um zelinski he
does his nightly address doesn't he to
the ukrainian people um and very many
ukrainians have also tried to flee the
country
even if there was a pause now how long
do you think it would take to start
to rebuild that country
of ukraine and for people to start to
return there
so i think we should be clear that
there's a pause as a result of perhaps
russia deciding to stop or run out of
steam is not a pause in any way for
ukraine ukraine will want to build the
military capability that it needs to go
on the offensive and take its country
back and whether that's this year later
on or more likely next year that's the
thing that will be in our laps next that
process of rebuilding the ukrainian
military to throw the russians out is at
least a year's work and will cost a lot
of money and a lot of effort from the
west but that's the demand that's going
to come
how wise is it to provide
weapons that could be used although the
ukrainians have said that they won't
could be used to fire into russia
i think with the war at the stage it's
now in so well developed in ukraine
quite a lot of this is priced in by all
sides i think what would make a
difference clearly would be if western
delivered weapons with long range long
range typically 150 to 300 kilometers
was actually used by ukraine to fire
into russia that i think
would would change the way russia
approaches this but the current
understanding that ukraine is given
weapons that give it the long range it
needs to to destroy russian artillery
before it destroys them but does not far
into russia i think that's a place that
most people will essentially live with
um okay it's good to talk to you thank
you so much for taking the time to join
us thank you